welcome to your mom's house
so was your birthday this week it was my
Smurf day by the way thanks for putting
it out there to the the general public
on Twitter get tell Tom how old you
think he is and quite a range you never
believe this but nobody actually guessed
the actual age everyone so we never get
significantly older yeah so I had
everything from I think the youngest age
I thought I saw was a happy 42nd
birthday and all the way up to I saw a
lot of hey next here's the big five oh
that's pretty cool
yeah all the way to 58 and 60 yes you
are a young 60 though I'm 60 years you
want to tell me what your actual ages or
do you want to leave it a mystery I'll
tell them yeah I now officially 37 years
old I remember flies by man 37 years
your life yeah and you know you can't
believe it like you hear it it doesn't
even sound right do you feel like you're
gonna die soon physically yes yeah I do
feel like I'm gonna do you really feel
like you're falling apart is that
happening for you no I mean this oh my
god put them on okay wait but do this
first look at the camera normal so that
they see what your eyeballs look like
and then put them on now it magnifies
your eyes you look like my nunna this is
what my grandma used to look like Nana
yeah big eyes are they're kind of cool
though I like the frames I like them
they just they make your eyes look
bigger well they make the words look
bigger too wait you can't see when you
don't know where did you get those at
the Rite Aid or those real get the fuck
outta here
these were a fortune I know glasses are
really expensive use this I know you
don't want to you don't want to fuck
those up and cost a fortune thing no but
my parents just would go to Rite Aid and
buy the Rite Aid ones I wear them to
read now and look again pewter basically
yeah yeah you're so old man oh man
duck so fucking bad well I had the I had
the vision test a year ago and they were
like I mean you could get him but you
don't need him and I was like okay did a
you know a year later I went for the
follow-up test and they're like you
absolutely need them now because of how
poorly I was doing and I fucking didn't
bring them when I renewed my driver's
license right and they go you know shit
that I've done for years where she's
like look up at that chart like okay she
goes a close one eye all right read line
four and I go AC dv7 she goes
seven seven and I go yeah and I took my
hand down and it was a tee and she goes
hold on read the and then she was now
you just looked both eyes go look in
this thing she made me go to something
else yeah and I was reading it like I
don't know if this is gonna fly right
now I you know I I was in like in a
little bit of a panic what if I fail the
vision test without these horse talks of
your whole world vision what happens to
you they don't know cuz I close one I
was reading through a little box you
know with like it that was backlit and I
I could see them but then there was one
that I couldn't really see and I go five
s because I was about to say a number
again I go SSS and she was like okay you
had me worried for a second I'm like you
fucking had me worried for a second yeah
so now I know that I got to bring these
more often you got to bring them
everywhere Jesus maybe have a pair that
you just leave in the car I'm gonna get
a second pair for driving yeah
Jeannie is out for driving too you need
to me they said I mean like you know I
see fine looking around whatever it but
they said if you're driving for a long
time you might want to bust my old I
know fuckin 70 so going down to drive
sometimes I Drive long and I don't see
so good